we have breaking news concerning those
two big Banks let's start with City
Group it's the third biggest US Bank if
you take a look at the numbers one spot
15 so15 a share beating the1 12 average
of those 23 analysts that we surveyed
right here at Bloomberg that essentially
benefiting from a stronger Us customer
and also from stronger international
business as well the firm also
announcing plans to exit consumer
banking in 11 markets for two specific
reasons number one in a statement they
said that they're going to focus on
countries that provide them more of a
competitive advantage and number two
they are looking for business units that
provide stronger returns we understand
that the sale these businesses are
already underway and are expected to be
completed by the end of next year a
couple of the places that they're
looking to exit from include places in
Costa Rica Japan Nicaragua just to name
a few although Betty they will continue
to work with institutional clients in
those economies so again City Group
beating in terms of that bottom line a11
12 vers a15 versus the average of A1 12
want to also focus in on Wells Fargo as
well this is the biggest US mortgage
lender as you say in line with estimates
we're talking for the three-month period
ending on September 30th $5.7 billion on
back of Revenue of
2121 billion net income coming in in
line at a dollar two a share that's
pretty much in line with those 25
analysts that we surveyed right here at
Bloomberg it looks like that as the big
US Banks essentially are grappling with
slowing demand for Home Loans Wells
Fargo has expanded business lines
including credit cards and Investment
Banking okay and I'm also looking at
some headlines here Mia about City Group
saying that after their banamex
investigation into that unit they have
uh they did in fact they did in fact
find illegal conduct and fraud uh this
is not materially that is is not uh
material to their financial uh to their
to their bottom line but they're just
but essentially they're saying that they
did find a fraud conduct in its banamex
unit uh and of course they're going to
hold those people accountable so just in
addition to some of the headlines you're
seeing scrolling out on the city group
results Mia thank you so much Mia sayy
at our breaking news desk